you have two enormous things easier Hema
2g this question number one I told you
was a big deal to do the diagram the
diagram is going to become very
important in a second and secondly they
even say they even give you the actual
method they want you to use for this
question they say using the focus
directrix definition orbit ellipse or
otherwise I'll give you tip the
otherwise almost always an algebraic
like disaster okay they're giving you a
big like green light go for this what is
the focus directrix definition of an
ellipse what is in terms of what we've
got here
young es
okay Mara we would usually don't dine at
this but we would usually say something
like this thank you good like that's
what we used to see okay Pierce is fine
they're gonna they've got the point yes
we however we say DB this direction
right but they've given a name to the
specific point on the directrix that's
being referred to this is actually a
more correct way of saying it because
I'm like these there's no D in the
diagram okay so therefore this is what
I'm normally see now how I look at
weight trying to prove there's this
stuff from all distractions right so
therefore in our context over here I'm
going to also write this as a fraction
so by then writing PS equals a p.m. I'm
going to write it as the actual ratio so
I've got PS on M is that all right now
that's a good start
however look again at what you're trying
to prove right
there's PS there but there's also PS -
right so they're comparing not just to
this focus but to the other focus does
that make sense so that clues means the
fact that this is not enough this is not
enough I also need to know that the
corresponding relationship would give me
are the focus will take me to the other
directions yes
so this yes
that also equals in okay so far so good
so that is me using the focus directrix
definition of the ellipse now again look
at those carefully look at what they're
trying to prove what would you do with
those two equations where would you go
when you're looking at what they're
asking for
yeah I clearly need to combine them in
some way because the result they have us
to prove has PSPs - even the same thing
and they're both equal to the
eccentricity so I could just equate
these two so I'm gonna say therefore ps1
and ps2
all right now this is good we've made
some progress I need to tweak this a
little bit to almost have exactly what
they're after
right that would PSR yes - which I don't
have on the left hand side what you like
to do
yeah I'm gonna get this kind of heat and
also at the PM's
over that way so I'm going to divide
through that PS - and how they multiply
through by p.m. so here we go
okay this is good I'm not there yet
yes yeah okay so so what should I do now
because this is nice and it's neat
it just happens to be wrong crying or at
least I'm more at the result and approve
what are you going to do with p.m. and
p.m. - because the left-hand side looks
good it's just the right inside yeah
okay so I really need to get at what is
this ratio I've got to stop doing just
[ __ ] around with algebra and I've got
to work out what these things actually
are I don't have any more algebraic
traits in order to get this to what are
we trying to get to an S and s that okay
so being the algebraic chicks are now
exhausted I look back at my diagram did
I say what kind of geometry can I take
advantage on so where are pier the pier
- where are they he's p.m. I need you
see that
and he's p.m. - okay now they've given
you some clues on this diagram that you
can just work with me like what is p.m.
- let me help you okay
first let's have a look at this distance
this is the distance the hochberg
perpendicular distance from access to
pick what that distance
Kathleen
it's the month it's justthis isn't it
right if this is you p2p which is just
the x-coordinate opinion so that's just
next boy are you okay with that now that
you've actually gone into the next week
which is now therefore p.m. like is this
distance takeaway that just says do you
agree right now that distance at the
time is just a or B right
so now let me tell it to my cat okay
p.m. I can see is this distance here
which is the what one takeaway the short
one
I'm gonna write a P and equals a or a
takeaway excellent
you're right be done so I actually know
what P f is equal to I'm just going to
substitute a on a takeaway explore now I
can make a very similar analogy when I
think about PE and - it's even easier
through the one I just did right
where's P of - over here the left hand
side right here it is it also I got this
length I can see look Tina is a on a
again right the distance anyway okay and
let me just need to add on X not to get
all the way there do you see it right
it's made up of these two pieces it's 1
& 2 so instead of doing a difference
like I did for p.m. I'm going to do a
sum that will give me
p.m. - okay that's nice I'm still not
there yet how do I connect this to this
are innocent a nurse - again you've got
them on your diagram did you see
so here's an what's this distance here
this distance to him it's a squared Expo
we just proved that right so this is a
square X 1 and NS is this bit
well again I'm going to use exactly the
same argument what's this total length
II think it's just the breakers
yeah just ie right so therefore NS is
just the difference appearance in fact
I'm doing exactly the same argument over
again right so I'll use this color so
this is a mess yeah and it is the
difference between a E and E to explore
there's a difference there you probably
a bit sick of me to the ocean yeah you
can see in this fashion is gonna be the
other thing but there's a song instead
of a difference okay now look look I
need to somehow get this which is on my
numerator I've got to get that looking
something like an S that's p.m. that's
NS what's the difference
okay I'm gonna multiple yeah I'm gonna
multiply through by E squared do you see
it right if I multiply this numerator by
d squared that a on e will turn into 80
and of course the X naught will turn
into a square next door okay so I'm
going to got to play through and I'm
going to do the same one thing tonight
obviously you can't just work around the
fraction subscribe okay excellent so
having witnessed Stephanie at bowling
how did I know to do this step like
where did that come from in my brain
yeah I was looking the geometry and
saying what NS has to look like it's I'm
gonna get to that somehow right so now I
multiply through this
and that that based on my diagram that
my friends is no no no penis